we've had a massive break in the Trump
Russia Fiasco and there is massive news
to report to you today which is that
President Donald Trump is now admitting
that yeah the purpose of his campaign
meeting with Russians that infamous day
in Trump Tower was specifically to
obtain dirt on Hillary Clinton during
the campaign they worked with Russia
President Trump admitting this in a
coordinated way with a scheduled meeting
meant to get damaging information for
the purposes of helping Donald Trump
defeat Hillary Clinton in the 2016
presidential campaign the circle now is
almost complete and remember we go back
to where the story started there was no
Russia story there were no meetings then
the right started shifting to collusion
wouldn't actually be a crime anyway and
then in the last couple of weeks last
week I reported to you that Donald
Trump's own attorney shifted from there
was no collusion there was no
coordination to I can't find in the
criminal code where it even mentions
collusion that was Rudy Giuliani last
week and now for the first time we have
Donald Trump personally admitting that
this Trump Tower meeting on June 9 2016
with Russian lawyer Natalia vessel
Mnet's kaya was not about adoptions it
was to get dirt on Hillary Clinton this
is working with Russia on the
presidential campaign here's Trump's
tweet from Sunday morning which was in
response it appears to a Washington Post
article pointing out that Donald Trump
jr. might be in serious legal trouble in
this entire thing that seemed to set
Donald Trump off who said quote fake
news reporting a complete fabrication
that I am concerned about the meeting my
wonderful son Donald had in Trump Tower
this was a meeting to get information on
an opponent totally legal and done all
the time in politics and it went nowhere
I did not know about it so Trump still
denying that he knew about it pretty
clear at this point that he did talked
about that last week claiming that it's
done all the time well not with foreign
countries we've heard from
Kratts and Republicans alike that if
they were approached by a foreign
country offering something like this
they wouldn't set up a meeting they
would call the FBI which we know the
Trump administration did not do but the
big news here it's important not to lose
the thread because Trump wants to focus
on it was legal and it was done it's
done all the time this is the first
admission from Donald Trump that the
meeting took place with the goal of
getting damaging information about his
opponent Hillary Clinton this is
something of value from a foreign power
and then of course aside from the
meeting itself this incident led to lies
from Trump about his involvement after
the fact he dictated the response letter
to this incident and the reporting of it
by the New York Times after initially
saying that he didn't dictate that
letter and the number two lies about the
subject of the meeting are now confirmed
eyed by Donald Trump we were initially
told it was about adoptions which in a
sense it kind of was
so the Magnitsky Act is related to
sanctions and adoptions is sort of quid
pro quo for its an intimated quid pro
quo that if the hillary dirt helps trump
win then the future trump administration
would look at rewarding Russia with
eased sanctions now we know because
Trump himself said it this was about
dirt on Hillary period Trump's campaign
was offered things of value by Russia
and they accepted the offer the only
step remaining
to fully close the circle would be proof
of what Trump's former personal lawyer
alleged last week which is that Trump
knew about the meeting in advance Trump
still claims that he didn't know about
that we don't know if we're eventually
going to get proof of that or not all of
the circumstantial and timing evidence
suggests Trump knew ahead of time and in
addition to that the question of whether
anything came of it the narrative so far
from people who have been caught lying
multiple times has been we had the
meeting we were promised dirt on Hillary
we wanted the dirt on Hillary but we
didn't ultimately get it that's what we
were told we didn't ultimately get the
dirt on Hillary what's going to be next
you know we got some dirt and it was
patriotic because it kept Hillary out of
the White House because Russia wanted
epic
make America great again winner Trump to
win that's the only part of the circle
left to be filled potentially hey I mean
these guys Donald Trump jr. Jared
Kushner they had never worked on a
political campaign before there was
their first time and sometimes when you
dip your toe into the water of a
political campaign you accidentally
commit a few federal offenses as well
happens to anyone what are the legal
implications this could make the Donald
Trump's admission that the the point of
this meeting was to obtain dirt on his
opponent from a foreign country this
could make the meeting itself conspiracy
with a foreign country this could make
the lies about the meeting obstruction
of justice conspiracy and false
statements to the feds if false
statements to the feds were made and it
appears that they probably were at this
point given what Donald Trump jr.
reportedly told investigators and and in
a hearing rather he is not necessarily
said that to investigators and what
Trump is now admitting the meeting was
for potentially multiple federal crimes
by many people implied by this tweet by
Donald Trump but the big question
remains which is will anyone and
specifically Trump pay for it and the
answer if you don't go out in November
and vote is probably not and by the way
still some people emailing me saying
there's no Russia story but very few at
this point very few people still
emailing me saying there's no Russia
story
lastly we always have to ask is this a
strategy or is this stupidity Donald
Trump saying this on Twitter it's never
clear it's a pot of possible strategy to
create chaos with the contradictions it
could be trying to get out in front of
the story before it breaks in a more
damaging way it could be idiocy and
ignorance it could be a combination of
all of these but what I returned to
every time is look at the evolution
there was no meeting there was a meeting
to discuss adoptions there was a meeting
to discuss dirt on Hillary but we didn't
get the dirt and the next logical step
if these are all lies is we did get dirt
but nothing illegal took place or we did
get dirt but we didn't ultimately need
it because Hillary's campaign was such a
disaster every single week we learn
about more lies that have been told to
us